[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
Präsident silensky in Washington
zweifellos die spektakulärste
Auslandsreise die ein Staatsoberhaupt in
diesem Jahr unternommen hat
guten Abend und ein Besuch mit hoher
Symbolkraft gleich auf mehreren Ebenen
der ukrainische Präsident der die Russen
ja eigentlich schon in den ersten
Kriegstagen beseitigen wollten zeigt
damit dass er sich nicht länger in einem
Belagerungszustand sieht sondern es
wagen kann sein Land zu verlassen und
sich mit seinem wichtigsten Unterstützer
persönlich zu treffen die USA wiederum
demonstrieren ihre nicht nachlassende
Solidarität denn sie lensky wird nicht
mit leeren Händen zurückkehren die
Amerikaner haben ihm versprochen was
Deutschland zuletzt nicht liefern wollte
oder konnte Patriot Abwehrsysteme
Claudia Bates berichtet
und kommt der Bericht noch
der Kontrast könnte nicht stärker sein
Präsident silenski aus der düsten ist
des Krieges aus der Zerstörung in der
Ukraine ist er gekommen in den
strahlenden Washingtoner Sonnenschein zu
freuenten diese Bilder sollen vor allem
ein Signal nach Moskau schicken ein
starkes Zeichen der Solidarität die USA
stehen an der Seite der Ukraine solange
es nötig sein wird
die Menschen in der Ukraine inspirieren
die ganze Welt das meine ich ernst nicht
nur uns sondern die ganze Welt mit ihrem
Mut und damit dass Sie sich entschieden
haben für Widerstandskraft und
Entschlossenheit für ihre Zukunft das
amerikanische Volk steht an ihrer Seite
Demokraten und Republikaner und unsere
Alliierten in Europa
unsere größte Wertschätzung aus meinem
tiefsten Herzen von meinem Volk allen
Ukrainern von meiner Nation danke für
ihre große Unterstützung
hatte vor den harten Wintermonaten noch
mal um Hilfe gebeten die hat Präsident
beiden heute zugesagt nochmals knapp
zwei Milliarden Dollar Militärhilfe
darunter das hochmoderne Patriot
Flugabwehrsystem das vor allem dabei
helfen soll die massiven russischen
Raketenangriffe auf die Infrastruktur
der Ukraine abzuwehren das Russland das
als Eskalation wertet lässt die USA kalt
sie sehen in Putin den einzigen der
eskaliert
das Ziel ist eine umfassende
Luftverteidigung für die Ukraine zu
entwickeln das könnte die wirksamste
Verteidigung sein gegen Putin und seine
Möglichkeit Raketen und Drohnen zu
benutzen um unschuldige Männer Frauen
und Kinder anzugreifen
am Abend wird silenski vor dem Kongress
seine Rede halten und nochmals die
Dringlichkeit der Hilfen betonen müssen
denn vor den Abgeordneten liegt der
Haushaltsentwurf für das kommende Jahr
zur Verabschiedung darin weitere 45
Milliarden Dollar an Hilfen für die
Ukraine doch in den Zwischenwahlen haben
die Republikaner die Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus gewonnen und einige
von ihnen haben die Zahlungen an die
Ukraine in Frage gestellt
unter republikanischer Mehrheit wird
kein Penny mehr in die Ukraine gehen
unser eigenes Land kommt zuerst
bei ihr und einigen anderen wird
selenski noch Überzeugungsarbeit leisten
müssen Präsident beiden dankt er mit
einer besonderen Geste er überreicht ihm
als Geschenk die Medaille eines
ukrainischen Soldaten Pavlo der sehr
tapfer sein
unverdient aber sehr wertgeschätzt sagt
beiden die Gespräche gehen noch weiter
da können die anwesenden Journalisten
sich noch so bemühen
Antworten auf Fragen gibt es erst bei
der Pressekonferenz in einer
Dreiviertelstunde
dass der Auftritt selenskys und die
Lieferung der begehrten Patriots in
Kreml Wut auslösen würde war klar
natürlich die besser die Flugabwehr der
Ukraine desto schwieriger wird es für
die russische Strategie das Nachbarland
aus sicherer Entfernung mit Drohnen und
Raketen zu terrorisieren Putin
verkündete heute russland werde alle
seine militärischen Ziele erreichen
koste es was es wolle ohne allerdings
näher zu definieren worin seine Ziele
mittlerweile bestehen die gesamte
Ukraine besetzen und kontrollieren
aussichtslos Krim und Don Bass behalten
das hatte er schon dafür hätten nicht
10.000 womöglich bereits hunderttausende
hunderttausend Soldaten sterben müssen
was also will er das Nachbarland einfach
nur noch zerstören
dadurch wird Russland aber auch nicht
größer Sebastian eben über Putins Pläne
und Probleme
immer im Dezember trifft sich die
militärische Elite Russlands um Bilanz
zu ziehen und um aufs kommende Jahr zu
blicken eigentlich ein Termin um die
Stärke der eigenen Streitkräfte zu
feiern doch dieses Jahr steht Putins
Armee unter Druck der Präsident sieht
sich vor 15.000 teils zugeschalteten
Offizieren genötigt klarzustellen wozu
Russland in der Lage ist
alles was der Kämpfer braucht muss
modern bequem und zuverlässig sein es
gibt keine Beschränkungen bei der
Finanzierung der Armee alles warum die
Armee bittet wird sie bekommen alles
putin will signalisieren wir geben nicht
klein bei im Gegenteil und so kündigt
auch Verteidigungsminister Scholl GU an
dass die sogenannte militärische
spezialoperation 2023 weitergehen wird
um die Ziele zu erreichen und um die
militärische Sicherheit für Russland
sicherzustellen ist es notwendig die
Anzahl der bewaffneten Soldaten auf 1,5
Millionen zu erhöhen
außerdem wolle man das Höchstalter der
Wehrpflichtigen auf 30 erhöhen und die
Armee besser ausrüsten
der Zustand unserer Streitkräfte unsere
vielversprechenden Waffentypen die
Ausrüstung die andere Länder nicht haben
aber wir schon
all das gibt uns Sicherheit und das ist
zu unserem Vorteil
wie zum Beweis inspizieren
Verteidigungsminister schorgu und
Vladimir Putin anschließend die neuesten
Waffentypen der Streitkräfte moskau will
heute eine Botschaft der militärischen
Stärke senden
mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Washington und Moskau MRT Wissen in
Moskau heißt die lisa hat ja schon
länger wir kämpfen gegen die NATO und
die Lieferung von Patriots die befeuert
das natürlich man hat den Eindruck das
Washington inzwischen darauf weniger
Rücksicht nimmt auf diese
Befindlichkeiten
keine Rücksicht mehr weil man das Gefühl
hat dass es eben dringlich ist ein enger
Berater von Präsident Weiden hat uns
Journalisten hier gesagt und wird auch
nicht drängeln nicht Ansporn noch nicht
einmal anpieksen das silenski nach einer
Verhandlungslösung suchen soll weil
Vladimir Putin eben weiter auf seinen
Maximalforderungen behaart weil er
Städte in Schutt und Asche legt weil er
die kritische Infrastruktur angreift und
vor diesem Hintergrund ist die Lieferung
des patricksystems sehr wichtig es hat
eine Reichweite von 1000 Kilometern kann
also eine weite Fläche abdecken schützen
vor innen reinkommenden Raketen und das
bedient Personal dafür etwa 1000
Personen sind notwendig Soldaten und
Techniker
auch in Deutschland ausgebildet werden
dann wird das System in die Ukraine
geliefert und dort ausschließlich von
Ukrainern bedient weil man eben eine
Schwelle nicht überschreiten will
nämlich den direkten Eintritt in diesen
Krieg und kann sich silenski zwar auf
Joe Biden und die Demokraten verlassen
aber er braucht natürlich auch das
amerikanische Parlament die diese Mittel
bewilligen wie viel Überzeugungskraft
muss er dabei seiner Rede nachher vom
Kongress aufbringen
also die muss ja aufbringen manche
fühlen sich erinnert an 1941 am 26
Dezember damals hat Winston Churchill
eine Rede vor dem Kongress gehalten an
die moralische Verantwortung Amerikas
appelliert im Krieg gegen eben das
Dritte Reich gegen die Nazis und in
diesem Fall wird selenski wahrscheinlich
auch an diese Situation erinnern es geht
darum auch Republikaner zu überzeugen
dass sie die Ukraine weiter unterstützen
mindestens mal in den nächsten Tagen mit
stimmen wenn eben 45 Milliarden Dollar
zusätzliche Hilfe für die Ukraine
beschlossen werden aber vielleicht auch
im nächsten Jahr wenn weitere
Hilfspakete notwendig werden
Putin hat ja der Armee heute unbegrenzte
finanzielle Mittel zugesagt aber die
muss man aber auch haben also hat Putin
die überhaupt ohne komplett auf
Kriegswirtschaft umzustellen
also ich denke putin wird Mittel und
Wege finden dieses Geld zu beschaffen
das ist natürlich hier allerhöchste
Priorität und deswegen wird das
natürlich ganz oben angesiedelt Russland
wird natürlich auch weiter versuchen
neue Abnehmer zu finden für sein Öl und
für seinen Gas um da eben Einnahmen zu
generieren dann wird es wahrscheinlich
aber auch nicht ohne gehen dass man im
Haushalt gewisse Umschichtungen macht
also dass man möglicherweise auch
Sozialleistungen hier verzichten muss
das andere Dinge gestrichen werden wie
große Infrastrukturprojekte und dann zum
Schluss kann Russland natürlich auch
neue Schulden machen
und will er außerdem mehr Soldaten sehr
viel mehr Soldaten aber das soll nicht
über erneute zwangsmobil machen
geschehen dann müsste es ja jede Menge
freiwillige geben wenn die Rechnung
aufgehen soll
ja das ist allerdings die große Frage ob
das tatsächlich so viele Freiwillige
geben wird sie könnten versuchen dass
eben so zu umgehen dass man bisherige
Militär Angehörige versucht in den
Dienst zu kriegen und es wurde heute ja
auch schon angekündigt dass das
einzugsalter für den Wehrdienst
angehoben werden soll von 27 auf 30
Jahre das wären dann möglicherweise auch
neue Soldaten die man in den Dienst
einziehen könnte das sind die
Überlegungen die es hier gibt und Putin
hat zwar heute gesagt dass es keine neue
Mobilisierung geben soll und als wir
diese erste mobilisierungswelle hatten
im Oktober hat das ja viele Russinnen
und Russen aufgeschreckt 100.000 haben
das Land verlassen weil sie eben doch
Angst hatten in diesem Konflikt
hineingezogen zu werden so nach und nach
erleben wir hier das ähm einige doch ins
Land zurückkommen weil natürlich
irgendwann das Geld ausgeht und die
Perspektive fehlt im Moment fühlen sich
diese Menschen halbwegs sicher aber so
richtig traut im Braten hier keiner so
richtig trauen die Menschen ihre Führung
auch nicht ob es wirklich dabei bleibt
ob es nicht im Frühjahr vielleicht doch
eine neue weitere Mobilisierung geben
könnte die dann vielleicht einfach
anders genannt wird
Dankeschön euch beiden nach Moskau und
Washington
Putin betonte in seiner Rede zwar
Russlands sah rüstungstechnisch autark
und anders als die Ukraine nicht auf
Hilfe angewiesen aber so ganz scheint
das ja nicht zu stimmen die sogenannten
Kamikaze drohen jedenfalls mit den
anderen Städte beschießt hat ihn Iran
geliefert auf die Müllers kann er
bislang zählen man ist geeint im Hass
auf dem Westen und in der Bereitschaft
das eigene Volk zu unterdrücken in der
Hinsicht erhofft sich Teheran wohl auch
russische Unterstützung denn anders als
die russische Bevölkerung hat die
iranische angefangen sich zu erheben und
lässt auch nicht nach ob das zu einer
neuen iranischen Revolution führen kann
darüber hat Kamera seit Jahren mit der
persischen ex-kaiserin paradiba
gesprochen
Tod dem Diktator rufen Sie in Tehran und
Tod der hinrichtungsrepublik die
Proteste in Iran halten an
Galgen hängen an einer Straßenkreuzung
als Mahnung und Protest laut Amnesty
International droht mindestens 26
verhafteten die Todesstrafe im Netz
verbreiten sich solidaritätsbotschaften
mit den Todeskandidaten
die persische ex-kaiserin faradiva ist
bestürzt über die Vorgänge in ihrer
Heimat wir treffen Sie exklusiv in Paris
täglich steht sie in Kontakt mit Iran
sagt sie erstmals spricht die 84-Jährige
im deutschen Fernsehen über die Proteste
in ihrer Heimat
es macht mich krank ich möchte gar nicht
darüber reden sie vergewaltigen junge
Männer und Mädchen Schießen auf sie was
hat man den Tätern in den Kopf gesetzt
das sind doch unsere Mitbürger es ist
schrecklich
militar
ich verliere nicht die Hoffnung denn
dort geht gerade eine Revolution
Freunde islamischen Revolution musste
auch sie mit ihrem Mann ins Exil fliehen
Rückblick
1967 wird Fahrrad zur Kaiserin gekrönt
der Iran erlebt eine Öffnung Frauen und
familienrechte werden gestärkt
doch auch die paravis waren bei vielen
im Land verhasst nicht zuletzt wegen
ihres berüchtigten Geheimdienstes
1979 werden sie von den Mulas aus dem
Land gejagt damals wie heute rufen die
Menschen nach Freiheit die exkaiserin
steht Fehler ein relativiert sie aber
und will den Blick nach vorne richten
es ist schön dass ich noch erleben darf
was in Iran passiert ich gebe zu dass
das Land unter uns damals Probleme und
Defizite hatte aber nicht bis zu diesem
Grad dieses schrecklichen Regimes heute
meine Waffe war und ist immer positiv zu
bleiben und daran zu glauben Licht wird
die Dunkelheit ablösen
die gestürzte Monarchin sieht nun das
molaregime vor dem Sturz und fordert von
den Machthabern in Teheran
don't kill and töten sie nicht die
jungen Menschen schießen sie nicht auf
sie sie sind ihre Brüder und Schwestern
sie sind ihre Kinder ihre Kinder müssen
mit Ihnen in Zukunft leben die Menschen
werden dieses Regime aus dem Weg räumen
Fahrrad Diba will den mutigen Frauen und
ihre Heimat weiter eine Stimme geben und
sie hofft trotz ihres Alters eines Tages
in ein freien Iran zurückzukehren
eine ausführliche Dokumentation zum
Kampf der iranischen Exil-Opposition
finden Sie bei ZDF heute unter den Titel
vereint gegen die Mullahs beobachtet
Kamera an wie sich im Ausland lebende
iranische Oppositionelle
zusammenschließen
und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter Heinz
es gibt neues von Donald Trump ja der
exus-präsident muss bei seinen
Auseinandersetzungen mit
Parlamentsausschüssen eine weitere
Niederlage hinnehmen jahrelang hatte er
sich dagegen gewehrt Steuerunterlagen
offenzulegen jetzt sollen sie zumindest
in Teilen veröffentlicht werden das
beschloss ein von den Demokraten
geführter Kongressausschuss Trump hatte
anders als es in den USA üblich ist
weder als Kandidaten noch als Präsident
seine Steuererklärungen öffentlich
gemacht
der Deutsche Städtetag befürchtet dass
sich die schon jetzt kritische Lage in
der medizinischen Akutversorgung über
Weihnachten und Silvester weiter
zuspitzt Hauptgeschäftsführer dedi
forderte gegenüber der Funke
Mediengruppe das Bund und Länder mit
Sofortmaßnahmen gegensteuern außerdem
bat er niedergelassene Ärztinnen und
Ärzte zu prüfen ihre Praxen auch noch
nach 18 Uhr am Samstag und Sonntag und
an den Feiertagen offen zu halten der
Vorsitzende des ärzteverbandes
virchow-bund Heinrich widersprach und
verwies darauf dass die Praxen in der
aktuellen Lage genauso belastet sein wie
die Krankenhäuser
in Großbritannien hat diesen Monat schon
das Pflegepersonal gestreikt jetzt haben
auch tausende Rettungskräfte und
Beschäftigte im britischen Rettungswesen
für 24 Stunden die Arbeit niedergelegt
sie streiten für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen und mehr Lohn das
Militär hilft bei Krankentransporten
außerdem hat die Regierung die Bürger
dazu aufgerufen auf riskante Aktivitäten
zu verzichten das britische
Gesundheitssystem nhls steckt in einer
Krise Krankenhäuser und das Personal
sind überlastet
die Bundesregierung reformiert eine
Reihe von strafregelungen nach einem
Kabinettsbeschluss soll unter anderem
die sogenannte
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe für nicht gezahlte
Geldstrafen halbiert werden auch
Strafverschärfungen sind vorgesehen und
zwar wenn die Motive für eine Tat wie es
heißt geschlechtsspezifisch oder gegen
die sexuelle Orientierung gerichtet sind
und das Kabinett hat Eckpunkte für eine
Ernährungsstrategie beschlossen mit dem
Ziel gesunde Ernährungsweisen für alle
so einfach wie möglich zu machen
beispielsweise durch entsprechende
Angebote in Betriebskantinen weniger
Fleisch dafür mehr pflanzliches soll auf
die Teller kommen mehr Bio und regionale
Produkte weniger Zucker Salz oder Fett
außerdem soll weniger essen im Müll
landen
derzeit besteht die Ernährungsstrategie
vieler Bundesbürger allerdings eher im
vertilgen weihnachtlicher Kalorienbomben
aber fürs neue Jahr kann man dann ja
wieder gute Vorsätze fassen
dieses Weihnachten wird aber ja bei
vielen eh schon weniger üppig ausfallen
Pandemien Krieg Energiekrise das
hinterlässt Spuren auf den Gabentischen
und im Einzelhandel dessen Bilanz ist
durchwachsen immerhin ist es nicht ganz
so schlimm gekommen wie viele
befürchteten und die Händler hoffen auch
noch auf einen jahresentspurt Andreas
Weise berichtet
süßer die Kassen nie klingeln als in der
Weihnachtszeit zumindest hier auf dem
Quedlinburger Weihnachtsmarkt scheint
das in diesem Jahr zu stimmen nicht nur
Bratwurst und Glühwein bringen
ordentlich Umsatz auch traditionelle
weihnachtsschnitzarbeiten aus dem
Erzgebirge finden ihre Käufer
das läuft wunderbar dieses Jahr wir
haben auch
jedes
das auch bei unserem mache ich das
wunderbar versucht uns Einnahmen sind
noch prima
also rund um zufrieden mit dem
Weihnachtsgeschäft zufrieden
zum ersten Mal seit 2019 ist wieder
richtig Weihnachtsmarkt in der
mittelalterlichen Welterbe statt hohen
Energiepreisen und Inflation zum Trotz
die Kunden hier sind bereit Geld
auszugeben
also wir haben darauf geachtet dass es
auch für den kleingeldbeutel reicht und
ja es läuft sehr gut wir können uns
nicht beklagen doch das positive Bild
aus Quedlinburg steht nicht für den
gesamten Einzelhandel Strukturwandel
digitale Konkurrenz viele
ladenschließungen während der
corona-pandemie und das
Weihnachtsgeschäft in diesem Jahr läuft
nicht für alle gut in 2022 müssen wir
eine gemischte Bilanz zum
Weihnachtsgeschäft ziehen nur ein
Viertel der Händler ist wirklich
zufrieden 50% sind unzufrieden die
Frequenzen in der Woche sind wirklich
nicht so gut gelaufen die Wochenenden
waren gut besucht auch dort wo
verkaufsoffene Sonntage stattgefunden
habe aber insgesamt ist doch eine Kauf
Zurückhaltung da die wir vielleicht auch
in der Größe nicht unbedingt erwartet
hätten
verkaufsoffene Sonntag als probates
Mittel zur Umsatzsteigerung das
funktioniert auch hier in Magdeburg in
diesem Einkaufszentrum im Herzen der
sachsen-anhaltischen Landeshauptstadt
herrscht vorrangig Zufriedenheit über
den Berg aber sind viele Händler noch
lange nicht
die Händler brauchen jetzt nach zwei
schweren Jahren tatsächlich ein gutes
Weihnachtsgeschäft man merkt einfach
dass da viele Rücklagen aufgebraucht
sind ich glaube man ist da auch noch
nicht am Ende der Fahnenstange es ist
ganz schwer zu sehen wie wird das
nächste Jahr wie wirken sich gerade auch
die angesprochenen Inflation die
Energiepreise auch auf die Unternehmen
aus und es wird mit Sicherheit auch der
ein oder andere noch vom Markt
verschwinden im nächsten Jahr die
Hoffnung vieler Händler ist das in
diesem Jahr zwischen Weihnachten und
Silvester noch etwas geht schließlich
haben die Läden nächste Woche von
Dienstag bis Samstag Mittag geöffnet
wir hoffen sehr dass das Wetter die
Stimmung der Leute und auch gerade
zwischen den Jahren noch mal die freie
Zeit mit der Familie auch genutzt wird
um in die Innenstädte zu gehen zu
bummeln und vielleicht auch geschenkte
Gutscheine oder auch Geschenk des
Weihnachtsgeld gleich wieder umzusetzen
und so haben viele auch noch nicht ganz
aufgegeben auf die alte Weisheit zu
setzen süßer die Kassen nie klingeln als
zu Weihnachtszeit
[Musik]
Zeit aber auch an jene zu denken für die
schon einen Glühwein auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt dann unerreichbarer
Luxus ist die Armut ist in Deutschland
gestiegen die Gründe sind vielfältig im
Franziskanerkloster in Berlin-Pankow
kennen sie die ganze Bandbreite
menschlicher Schicksale Altersarmut die
von den Betroffenen oft schamhaft
verborgen wird
Langzeitarbeitslose die nicht
vermittelbar sind
eu-saisonarbeiter die hier gestrandet
sind geflüchtete oder auch Menschen die
durch psychische Krankheiten oder
drogenabhängigkeiten den Halt verloren
haben
sie alle sind willkommen in den
Suppenküchen der Mönche in denen es weit
mehr gibt als eine warme Mahlzeit
Christa Läpple berichtet aus Berlin
Berlin Pankow Wollankstraße sitzt der
Franziskaner eine gute Adresse hier
befindet sich Berlins größte Suppenküche
das beste dieser Ort funktioniert
täglich gibt es hier eine warme Mahlzeit
umsonst eine Anlaufstelle für viele
Berliner 1990 wurde mir die Arbeit
genommen weil eben diese scheiß Einheit
kam und so alleine bin zu Hause und
Kochen lohnt sich nicht für mich alleine
essen und essen ist ja ganz wunderbar
Punkt 12 vor 45 wenn die Glocke läutet
beginnt die Essensausgabe seit über 30
Jahren eine warme Suppe für die Ärmsten
der Armen bis zu 150.000 Portionen im
Jahr ein Segenswunsch gehört zu
Tradition
ich wünsche allen guten Appetit
[Musik]
zur Zeit kommen jeden Tag über 200
hungrige Menschen ihre Gründe sind
vielfältig Wohnungskündigung
Firmenpleite und Obdachlosigkeit
Scheidung Schulden und Kader Altersrente
Alkohol oder Depression in der
Suppenküche wird niemand nach dem Warum
gefragt ich habe selber zehn Jahre in
einer Obdachlosen Siedlung gewohnt im
Ruhrgebiet und ich habe 25 Jahre bei
psychisch Kranken in Psychiatrien
gearbeitet das heißt wir Franziskaner
sind gerne bei den Menschen am Rand
die Suppenküche wird zu 100% aus Spenden
finanziert das große Glück der
Franziskaner ihnen wird weiter geholfen
trotz Krieg Krise und Inflation
freiwillig mit Geld spenden oder warmen
Sachen
umsonst wird hier gewaschen oder
medizinisch geholfen über 150
ehrenamtliche gehören zum Team ihr Motto
Arm überleben ist eine Kunst wir helfen
den künstlernen
improvisieren
die Suppenküche von Pankow ein
Lichtblick in der krisengeschüttelten
Hauptstadt zu Weihnachten gibt es extra
Kekse die Wünsche hier sind bescheiden
für alle Gesundheit mehr wünsche ich mir
nicht dass der Heilige Geist in Moskau
landet Frieden auf der Welt aber das
Wetter
die Suppenküche ist dann Heiligabend
geöffnet wie das ganze Jahr über
wenigstens darauf ist in Berlin Verlass
[Musik]
und jetzt macht Heinz Wolf noch mal
weiter mit einem ganz anderen Thema mit
dem Kurznachrichtendienst Twitter es
gibt die nächsten Schlagzeilen und
Fragezeichen zu dessen neuem oder
möglicherweise bald altem Chef Elon Musk
Frank beetmann wie ist da der aktuelle
Stand ja Elon Musk inszeniert sich mal
wieder zunächst ließ er nach anhaltender
Kritik an seinem Führungsstil unter den
Nutzern abstimmen ob sie ihn weiter als
Twitter Chef haben wollten als die
mehrheitlich nein sagten twitterte Mast
nun ich werde als CEO zurücktreten
sobald ich jemanden finde der blöd genug
ist den Job zu übernehmen danach werde
ich nur noch die Software und Server
Teams leiten unausgesprochen bleibt das
Masken natürlich auch weiterhin das
Sagen haben wird ganz einfach weil er
den Kurznachrichtendienst erst kürzlich
für viel Geld gekauft hat doch Twitter
so scheint es wird für den Tech Media
der mehr und mehr zum Klotz am Bein
mehrfach schon betonte mask an der
Spitze von Twitter das sei keine
Dauerlösung schließlich leitet er ja
auch noch kon gerne wie die raketenfirma
SpaceX oder Tesla gerade dem
elektroautobauer hat das
twitter-techtelmechtel seine Chefs sehr
geschadet der Kurs der Aktie viel seit
der Übernahme um über 40 Prozent
wichtige Investoren von Tesla beschweren
sich mittlerweile lautstark
mastverhalten bei Twitter würde der
Marke Tesla Schaden und obendrein allen
Beteiligten viel Geld kosten Frank
Wittmann vielen Dank und jetzt die
Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewähr 2 22 24 42 47 49
Superzahl 1 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 557
die Bestsellerautorin Barbara Noack ist
tot wie ihr Verlag bekanntgab starb sie
gestern im Alter von 98 Jahren in
München bereits ihr zweiter Roman die
Züricher Verlobung von 1955 wurde zu
einem großen
publikums-serie der Bastian der
fernsehhit mit horst Janson in der
Hauptrolle spiegelt das Lebensgefühl der
70er Jahre die Serie erzählt die
Geschichte eines angehenden Lehrers in
München
und zum Schluss möchten wir sie noch mit
etwas schönem in den späten Abend
verabschieden mit Musik und taz eine der
größten Klassiker wird neu aufgeführt
die West Side Story es geht in neuer
Version auf Welttournee und das von
München aus mehr dazu von Barbara
[Musik]
zwei Gangs bekriegen sich zwei verlieben
sich
New York in den 50ern ein Welterfolg
unsterblich
[Musik]
es ist eine Geschichte die jeden
Menschen in seinen Niederungen und
besten Seiten anspricht das macht sie so
beliebt einfach großartig
[Musik]
New York
riesencasting vorab für diese
Welttournee über 3000 Bewerber 34 haben
es bis hierher geschafft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sobald man die Musik hört fesselt sie
die Geschichte basiert ja auf Romeo und
Julia das ist zeitlos geschrieben für
Jahre im Jahres
schlaflos Ring der Junge Bernstein
damals um jede geniale Note dann die
Premiere 1957 ein paar Jahre später
reißt die erfolgstruppe nach München zum
ersten Mal sehen Sie in Deutschland die
berühmte Westside Story
und währenddessen wird sie in New York
für Sohn Alexander zum Soundtrack seiner
Kindheit seines ganzen Lebens
[Musik]
today die Geschichte ist immer noch
aktuell die Musik so frisch
ich habe es schon bestimmt tausendmal
gesehen ich liebe das Stück wie einen
Bruder
mit dieser neuen Inszenierung wollen sie
die Geschichte jetzt auffrischen die
nächste Generation begeistern und das
auf höchstem Musical Niveau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tanzen ist schwer singen ist schwer
spielen ist schwer auf allen Ebenen
anspruchsvoll für Körper Geist und
Energie
[Musik]
auf der Sie mit dieser neuen West Side
Story sicher Funken schlagen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war's von uns und gleich im
Anschluss können sie mitfahren auf einer
Reise durch Schottland und gegen eine 40
meldet sich dann Gundula Gause mit
unserem heute-update bis morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die
weltmeteorologieorganisation hat den
klimastatusbericht für das Jahr 2022
veröffentlicht und diese Karte stellt
das Jahr 2022 im Schnitt da wir sehen in
Europa war es deutlich zu warm es ist
eines der Hotspots ja im Schnitt für
dieses Jahr und wir sehen auch noch
etwas anderes und zwar diese kühlen
Flächen hier über den Pazifik vor
Südamerika das ist auf das Phänomen la
Ninja zurückzuführen und trotz dieses
kühlenden Effekts fällt das Jahr 2022
unter die acht wärmsten Jahre und das
sind die vergangenen acht Jahre wir
schauen auf das Wetter mit Wärme haben
wir es weiterhin zu tun von Westen her
kommt recht milde Luft und wir bekommen
ja das übliche weihnachtst weiter und in
der Nacht dazu vor allem Regen was nach
Südosten zieht ja und im Südosten sind
die Böden gefroren dementsprechend
müssen Sie hier noch mal mit Glätte
rechnen bei Temperaturen bis minus ein
Grad dort acht Grad entlang des Rheins
und neun Grad Richtung Oberrhein morgen
im Tagesverlauf werden mit viel Wind
Regen und Wolken über das Land getrieben
teils stürmische Böden sind dabei ganz
im Norden ist es gar nicht mal so windig
ja und da gibt's auch etwas Sonnenschein
dazu bei höchsten Temperaturen von 5 bis
14 Grad das ist die Temperatur Spanne
und die nächsten Tage ja es bleibt
windig und Milch von Südwesten kommt
viel Regen auf bei 5 bis 15 Grad am
Freitag und auf die Weihnachtsfeiertage
sind mild und nass ein schöner Abend